a YouTuber in UK made some derogatory
comments regarding Andrew which went
viral and he replied straight away and
insulted all Muslims although I would
gladly blow myself up I'm just saying if
he really wants to prove it do the right
thing
let's see how it's hysteria let's see
how about that life you really are then
the Muslims blow themselves up and I
should go blow myself up after me
converting to Islam he made a piece on
one of his podcasts saying that I'm not
true in my conversion and then insulted
all Muslims then the Muslims blow
themselves up and I should go blow
myself up we should all blow ourselves
up making racist comments about about an
entire religion as if that's somehow
funny
let me tell you something my friend and
if true Geordie if you're watching this
this is a message directly to you
there are certain times in life you need
to know when to shut up
[Music]
this is the danger
assalamu alaikum greetings of peace now
most of you by now have seen the video
of Andrew Tate praying in a mosque
[Music]
and then the news shortly after that
announcing that he was officially a
Muslim this is Allah
one who has submitted his or her will to
the creator of the heavens and the herb
just like Moses Jesus Abraham the last
final messenger said to mankind Prophet
Muhammad but who is the brother praying
next to him you also the man himself
here what canceled the legend is here
inshallah his new home I'm gonna bring
you a very special show soon to all the
people who supported him his hallway bro
thank you very much
glad to be here
foreign
and what impact did he have in his
decision except Islam well my next guess
is an ex-professional MMA fighter turned
entrepreneur and father he competed in
MMA across the world before retiring in
2010 so let's find all this out from the
man himself Tam Khan assalamu alaikum my
brother
how are you my brother alhamdulillah
thank you for joining us it's a big
pleasure brother I'm a big fan of what
you do I love the show and I'm very
humbled to be invited to be honest
that's nice to hear alhamdulillah very
nice thanks for accepting the the
invitation all the way from UAE huh yeah
right now it's 8 40 p.m in the UAE in
Dubai
and I'm in my gym uh podcast room
you're kind of like you gotta you gotta
that's pretty cool I'm here in the
studio but you have a gym also I have a
I have a gym myself here in uh Chicago I
teach also uh mixed martial arts uh
Gracie Brazilian Jiu Jitsu at the same
time yeah yeah that's my background too
crazy oh yeah yeah I'm a
huge advocate and fan of the original
martial art which led to the Mixed
Martial Arts I'm a very good friend with
hoist himself actually oh that was my
first uh teacher who I got my Bluebell
from
Torrance California I I used to travel
to Torrance California that's when
horion was still there kaike was still
there a hoist was there and then you
know they split up of course yeah yeah
so that's why that's the roots that's
the true roots of Brazilian well it was
Gracie Jiu Jitsu until it changed I
don't know copyright copyright reasons
yeah and then I started training I
started going to uh Brazil training with
Carlos Gracie Jr well uh starting with
Gracie Baja and then we we've now
branched out to a reservix jiu jitsu yes
here so hopefully we can have you uh
have you been to the states here in
Chicago or anywhere well Chicago I've
been on the East I've been to New York
Philly and things but I've never been
but inshallah you know I want to do a
trip soon I've got children maybe take
them to a Disneyland stop off maybe roll
in your Academy who knows oh I gotta
even I got an even better idea what
we're going to hopefully inshallah soon
be opening the dean center in Tampa
that's about an hour from Orlando we
need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah our brother Eddie
is setting up the dean Center not just
the dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
[Music]
so we'll have also along with the uh the
mega dawa Center we'll have an Athletic
Facility there also some Jiu Jitsu so
yeah
I'd love to visit it it'll be great
alhamdulillah so we got a lot in common
there so tell us now you uh what led up
to this uh
this uh prayer video that now you and
Andrew Tate you're in a Masjid you
brought them into a mosque and you guys
are side by side praying please talk to
us about this yeah I mean what people
don't know is me and Andrew go back
maybe 15 years Andrew
made his debut or fighting on one of my
shows in Essex a little town on the
suburbs of a the UK Southeast
and um so I've known him I've known his
coach who's a Muslim Bosnia Muslim Amir
he came from he was coached and
basically his mentor was a Bosnian
Muslim Amir he's a very respected guy on
kickboxing in their area called Luton
I'm from South and once in Essex so we
knew each other you know like you have
peers in the martial arts world so then
I moved to Dubai in 2008 and every time
he'd come we'd touch base he'd reach out
let's catch up you know a lot of the
guys from the UK I'm kind of their go-to
guy if I mix martial arts or catching up
if you know someone it's like I'll reach
out to term he's in Dubai like that we
kept in touch and um
then obviously he blew up we stayed in
touch and I saw him become a viral
YouTube Star
and um the funny thing is when I used to
watch him I still agree with a lot of
things I was like hey Andrew like you
know I love what you're saying like uh
not everything but a lot of the gist to
what he would say we can as Muslims
relate to it was very
different you know as you know from uh
non-muslim to speak in these things
publicly and having no kind of
borrow limit to what he said he had no
fear so cut a long story short we're in
Dubai and um
reach out we well he's here at the
moment he's based here right now so he
he knows me trust me you know we go way
back and a lot of people he meets he'll
come to me and say who's this guy is he
good because he obviously with his
status he has to be a bit careful when
you've got the people against you the
powers that be
but then um we were discussing we were
sitting actually with Steven Seagal a
few nights before
and uh I said you know what I'm gonna
take you we need to go marches one day
because I want you to feel
how that connection is between the
Creator and the creation I can't explain
I said just when you go on a Masjid
quietly and you put your
forehead to the floor it's just
something special he said bro it's my I
would love to do it I would love to and
it wasn't like you know I wanted to test
his reactions some people be like yeah
yeah okay you know they don't want to or
maybe one day he was like yeah I love to
and then uh he said to me you know what
but I'm really I want to convert to it
anyway he brought this up oh really I
got a martial arts for sure that's
that's like the goal
so two three days later there was a UFC
that night it was an Abu Dhabi uh Islam
against Charles Oliveira we were going
to go to the event then we didn't last
minute we just thought he gets a lot of
kids chasing and we said you know what
let's watch in a local uh fast food
restaurant in Dubai so that day I was
waiting for him I said okay let's go uh
at a certain time so we were supposed to
meet them he messaged me uh where are
you I'll pick you up
and there was traffic I said you know
what I'll drive and we'll meet there
I've completely forgot at this point
about the monster he said uh no but
we're gonna go to mushrooms no I said
you're right so I said okay you picked
me up and I will go together so he
reminded me this is no uh script
he picks me up in the most his famous
Bugatti what color is your Bugatti
so we go to a Masjid and it's just after
Isha I think
30 minutes after Isha so it's kind of
quiet people pray that Jamal and they
believe there's two guys in there
some local workers or staff from the
mall is connected to them all
so I said okay he's all covered I said
you're you have to have a ablution when
we pray it's called wadu Uh you clean he
goes yeah I've showed anyway so walking
I said look let's pray he goes yeah I
said you don't mind so I
obviously on the video people are saying
there's a gap obviously the Brother's
first time so yeah I mean it's obviously
you make these things happen and I just
said look uh try and focus looking
downwards I'm gonna do the Salah just
I'll pray for us there's some things you
won't know I'll try and do it whispering
it in such style which is not normal but
just try and repeat that and then uh at
the end I'll turn to the right shoulder
say salaam to one Angel then the left
shoulder and then we've prayed so we did
too novel then again I thought you know
what let's film this I said you know why
because you're sure I said yeah let's
film it because
he goes people will say yes it doesn't
matter I said I'm gonna film it because
I just think you get so much stick let's
put this up there to show it will
influence young Muslim people who follow
you too many kids want to be rappers too
many kids want to be I'm a Gangster they
said let's put something positive from
someone they look up to so there's a
young uh a cleaner or someone I said
please can you record this so he held it
with the two more knuckle and uh and
that's the video which went viral
and uh I said I'm gonna post this you
don't mind he doesn't know well go ahead
because you're sure I said sure I said
but I've got a feeling this is going to
blow up and I said but it's for good
reasons I said sometimes social media
can be used uh in a productive way in my
opinion there's many
many opinions on this oh why did you do
it you shouldn't be recording yourself
look for me
social media is such a powerful tune I
like yourself people watch you to
connect to the younger generation people
like yourself like me like I would say
you can't just have 75 year old imams
given speeches they can't relate to them
well there's you've got to use different
angles and when arrow take is so popular
really like from that it just a lot I
had people messaging me we were in tears
watching this we're crying thank you so
much you hit us brother saying to me you
know I feel ashamed to pray I'm always
out doing this and that to watch him
pray make made me feel ashamed that I'm
gonna go to imagine now so it is what we
want and then the next day obviously it
went viral and I saw reposts from
YouTube channels and things like that
and yeah all of a sudden people think
I'm Mufti I'm not a muffin I'm not a
scholar I'm another brother I I'm trying
to perfect myself also you know at what
point in your life did you start to turn
to take life more serious asking the
crucial questions what's the purpose of
life why am I here at what point in your
life did you really start to take it's
not more serious
honestly I'll give respect to my mother
she raised me alhamdulillah in a good
way I've never deviled an alcohol drugs
but of course I wasn't practicing I'd do
other activities which are frowned upon
but I always was God fearing but
and I I wasn't praying five times but
call me a German Muslim as you say and I
do the fast Ramadan I never miss a fast
but it was only in these times I always
think here tomorrow or
but then when I had children I'd always
be around the dean I'd always watch
Brothers I'd go to speakers called I'd
speak to Brothers I'd enjoyed that I I
read a lot but then I thought
I'm not like I'd wake up to watch a UFC
at 5am imagine not fudger it's one day
when I had kids like I always wanted
children and I could not ever have
children
and I pray to our life things like this
and I had a few circumstances in my life
I don't talk about trials and
tribulations
where at that time it was the lowest
part of my life I turned only to the
Creator nothing could help money people
your so-called friends run away
local Big Man local tough guys local
influencers no one could help so
I prayed five times I prayed all this
not only five times somehow nothing and
I did the hajjood and I remember one of
my brothers Championship
there's a quote or how do you tell it he
said like a Target it's like an arrow
that never misses a Target
I was doing the the door after after the
hour before my group on a Friday I was
doing everything and I really got into
it
and then I went to umrah as well and
everything just clicked and subhana what
I used to pray for in the hajjad what I
used to pray for
this image exactly I looked back months
later it was there okay
it's like just a power of the creation
it's like Allah
answered my device because our prayers
because he's maybe saw my intention and
I made a promise stuff right I know
people say you cannot do that but I
promise I'll I'll try my best to this
day I will never ever
knowingly go off off the path like for
this day at once I'm going to make sure
I do my best as a Muslim and however I
can and never miss [ __ ] and since then
God forbid if one or once in a month if
I've overslept on my alarms whatever
happens I literally my day's ruined so
it took me time but um and I've been on
the internet since then like I'm trying
to speak to Brothers around me people in
the gym the younger generation look up
to me if we have WhatsApp groups I'm
kind of like the motawa they don't send
certain pictures I tell them listen pray
do this why are you not praying if
they're all around me I say I'm praying
come on do that uh do the we'll do let's
jump in and it helps a lot of guys and a
lot of people have started following
suit praying as well
uh we've had a few new reverts so
for me like around Andrew when he saw
that that I don't joke in a certain way
if Salah comes I walk out of a meeting
whether it's a government Builder
wherever I'll pray on the street I'll
pray in the corner too he says you know
what I respect I respect someone who's
with
their religion or faith rather than the
guy who will try and press someone to
not be with it so he's like that he's as
you know he's a man's man he's not a guy
who's very influenced by others he'll
speak his mind
and the problem you get with a lot of
Muslims will be oh Andrew it'll be like
this we love you we love what you say
but it's a lot of time they'd rather sit
there and take pictures than you know so
in life
we only have to impress one person or
one entity that's the creation and the
rest as you know and I've got that point
in my life where I used to be Vain and
so I want to look like this I want to be
the strongest ego
when you get close to Allah you have
more patience summer less ego you don't
back by your whole character changes to
the point I think I've gone too soft too
soft around my kitchen I've become in a
nice way you know so um I also have
aggression problems and this and that
but somehow the power of our line
like us we're discussing is 2022 in
November social media on a peak and
we're sitting on a in different
countries discussing Islam so it just
goes to show the miracle of this
beautiful religion that you're in this
world I'm in this world we're around
celebrities but nothing will change
nothing will divert us you could I said
to Andrew take once I said you could put
a billion dollars to a real Muslim any
Muslim whether he's praying or not a
billion dollars cash and say denounce
Islam and 99 will never do it but you
could do that to any other religion they
would for a billion dollars and that's a
lot of money cash and he goes you know I
guess no one will do it so whether we
sin or not or whether people are off the
path that's the belief we have and
that's something you that's a miracle I
guess of the final uh Revelation you
know that's uh beautiful to see you know
someone who's uh not ashamed to to be
one who is representing his Dean and
shine away people talk about football
basketball UFC everything under the sun
you know conversations that lead here
there anywhere but you know you're
bringing up you know proud to go ahead
and talk about the way of life that the
Creator set down for all of mankind and
it's uh it's really nice to see that
there's a a video here also I wanted to
share did you guys walk into a Institute
of Education here I'm glad he's here you
know as well as I told him what you're
with us his brother
invites it off
we're invited by the miss them
have Ministry of sport Ministry
education there's nothing about religion
but there's a little bit of complaining
that most people have been saying this
is
from a book of guidance how to pray and
uh just got guys and
while about brother Andrew is he gets
invitation let me tell you my phone is
non-stop every day millionaires Captain
this that business is when I bring him
he's literally like bro I don't want to
go I really want to relax if it's
business we can discuss but every time
we've been invited to a Islamic Center
or a Masjid without a doubt he just says
what time and he goes and you see him
you see himself I can't explain you have
the aura the sunglasses the top G
aggressive but when he's in these places
well you see nor in his face and it's
like a relation he relates to it and he
lights up the brothers we walked into
another one
on Flag Day last Thursday to a Muslim
Community Center and it's where they
have speeches on reverts he walked into
a room they made him stand up and asked
why he reverted and you could see the
faces off well so this is happening or
not just this time but this is also
there's more one I'll post soon it was
last Thursday and it was really nice
because it was a class full of reverts
they go to learn about Islam study
understand the Five Pillars regarding
how do you do umrah Hajj and I think
they were learning
the steps of Umar and we walked into the
class and the speaker said by the way
would you mind talking for a few minutes
we got outspoken the rivers was so happy
it made them feel but maybe some you
know feel a bit nervous or can I do this
and when they saw him they felt calm and
like I said I reverted someone in my gym
a guy who trains here last week from
Holland and she told by that I've got a
few questions and I'm just worried my
parents you know they're very
anti-islamic and they're from Holland or
this to us or brother just do it for
Allah don't have to tell them for now
just do it because tomorrow's never
guaranteed let's just do it and step by
step and if they say things don't argue
with it if I wasn't I'd have the same
ideas some Muslims don't do it I said
say inexpension this is not the religion
but the people are different we can't
judge on this and uh he felt calm he
reverted and that day he felt so good we
had dinner after so alhamdulillah I'm
not sure where there was Andrew but
since then it has more
pros and cons should I put it you know
so did he end up taking his his official
uh shahada did he take it at this
institute or was it with you before
before made that same day but it was
privately done he did it they're
actually in UAE you guess location for
um
for becoming a Muslim it's like a thing
they do in the UAE in the UK is
different you say shahada and you know
you have your Witnesses Allah knows best
but uh so that he wanted he said can you
send us your possible copy and we'll get
this done for you so yes please I'd love
it so they're going to make him an
official certificate of being a revert
to Islam on the UAE government so wow
yeah so subhana it was a beautiful and
they gave him a a beautiful uh prayer
mat Quran he's got guidance books we've
got a few WhatsApp groups with some well
good hours in London and in the UAE so
this is not something hard to comprehend
Islam is a the natural way it connects
with the human nature the Instinct that
we're all the fitra you know the
Incarnation it's it's not something that
you have rocket science to figure out
worship the Creator not the creation be
a good human being you know live upon
these morals that God Almighty Allah has
sent and we have the living Miracle the
Quran if anyone is sincere it takes uh
analytical scientific approach comes at
it sincerely and they're asking to be
guided by the Crater they're going to
see the truth just like Andrew taped it
it's very straightforward it's not like
you're trying to convince someone that
God is a man or that you know some of
these strange beliefs that are out there
these man-made religions Islam is clear
it's pristine the toheed the pure
monotheism is something that's easy to
digest
yeah it is and I think
what he respects a lot was like you said
how Islam doesn't Bend its rules we
don't try and adapt to society we have
our set ways and that's it's Timeless
yes we respect the laws of the land as a
properly taller
if anything is going to influence our
religion then we step in so unlike other
religions and obviously his delivery is
a little bit different but he says
things like
having a trans or a Christians or
priests who allow homosexuality for
example we know clear-cut in certain
books is forbidden it doesn't make them
not Muslim if there was a Muslim person
who promises it doesn't make them a
Muslim means you're sinning
can't control your pleasures or your
desires same as way as a Muslim who
commits dinner
like a man just control your desires you
know so Islam has sets of rules and and
I said to him like
UAE or in the Middle East you could
leave your phone or a pot of gold
sometimes
brother in in
sane summer it's so hot here you have to
if your car's outside you have to leave
the engine on imagine doing that Lana I
leave my engine on going to a meeting
for 30 minutes my car where the keys are
inside AC's running and I come back it's
not touched
that goes because that all stems from
Islamic kind of ruling respect the laws
of a land and I think if the West I'm
not saying bring I'm saying if they
adopted some ways of that you it'd be a
happier place and he identified that he
said look the West is upside down we
work hard for watches or
material things you can't even wear them
in London now people talk to you so what
kind of society is that you pay taxes
the police have no power
people are like he said he's literally
said you can you see people fornicating
on beaches and probably everyone it's
just wild west he goes to buy I like the
system he goes I like where if you have
a partner or your wife she's safe your
kids can run in the mall I can have my
kids run around make a mess and come
back no threat of pedophilia or these
grooming you know and that all stems
from Islam whether we're not talking
about leadership or if it's clear
because Sharia law we're not saying that
but we're saying
these values and rules Come From Islam
and Society in general is a better place
and now you're seeing Dubai it's the Hub
of the world people are moving
westerners all of Europe Germany
Switzerland you name it they all come in
here it's because the way of life is the
better so um
I think that's a testament to the
original itself and
it's like in the early 2000s
unfortunately when that incident
happened in 911 Islam wasn't a rock time
but the wall was against it
the invasions of Afghanistan Iraq but I
think
it's kind of full circles come because
people are fed up with the West at the
moment and it's not just Muslim there's
non-muslims they're Fed Up of agendas
being pushed on their kids or Society or
saying there's certain pronoun they're
thinking okay agree or not but don't
push on us like we don't come to you and
say become Muslim or do this we don't we
say this is our message if you like it
or not or follow us so even non-muslims
atheists they're all on the same boat
that's why I think you're seeing a big
increase in reverts and I think it all
like is promised to us in our books as
well like Islam will always Prevail you
can shun us you can say this back why I
say way backward but the message is it's
a miracle and when someone hears the
message unless they're not educated
enough I think they'll always come to
Allah because I think
we're all educated people we're well
studying I I at a time in my teens I'd
look at all the religions I looked at
everything I wanted to say Let's test
and so Paula you always come back to
Islam the miracle of the Quran Miracle
of the Hadith the prophet sayings things
he predicted which are happening now
we talk that to Andrew I said imagine he
said there'll be a time when
the Barefoot Bedouin Arab will be
competing over the highest buildings
imagine that those times Persia Romans
were known for buildings Arabs had
nothing yeah look at the Middle East or
clear prophecies yeah yeah prophecies
which you could not predict 50 1400
years ago so no way all the description
of the fetus or things like this
anywhere in the Quran it's just the
embryo is scary and like not scary in a
good way in a when people have an open
heart and are willing to listen I don't
believe there's any way to go against it
in my opinion and I think the only
people who do have agendas or they have
businesses which profit are going
against it that's the only reason why
not so I'll handle like it really made
me happy to see I'd rather see a brother
like Andrew become a Muslim than me
having all the success in business I'd
rather give up and see someone like you
know it makes me more happier because I
know his influence will be key and I
just want to say one thing I don't want
everyone to say he's not going to become
a Mufti or scholar overnight he's not
going to be there so don't look to him
for Islamic dawah and don't
say okay he did this that because his
new Twitter is going to take time so a
lot of people will send me comments and
I see messages oh he has a cigar here or
he's there guys we have to relax the
guys change from one opposite a
multi-millionaire popular celebrity you
call it from this to this
majority of us would fail it's not easy
you know brother like
industry is so different so
[Music]
I'm a Muslim and I respect the religion
so let him be
um step by step it will come with time
and I think the oldest worry I have is
the pressure of Muslims
won't bothering him when you did this
wrong I saw this video I saw this that's
the thing so but as long as we can back
off and show support I think inshallah I
can see no problem
uh it's interesting that uh I'm gonna
share this clip that he's already
inviting people to uh look into Islam
you know if you've got yourself a nice
Islamic wife she wouldn't cheat on you
she'd cook for you she'd look after you
she wouldn't have an only fans you know
most of the problems you're facing
currently with women can be solved by
Islam
really I just told you why wait they
actually don't cheat she'd have decency
she'd cover up she'd be God-fearing if
she her family would also keep an eye on
her so her family would tell her to obey
her husband she'd want your children
she'd look after you Islamic women are
the best they understand that the best
way to serve God is to also serve their
husbands where do I get one at well most
of your problems could be solved where
do I get an Islamic you must become a
Muslim yourself first my friend
and and being a Muslim is not easy
there's a lot to learn it's a long
journey even I'm not a scholar I'm
learning there's a lot to learn about
how it works and the true word of God
and the Quran and learning Arabic Etc is
not easy but if you come to Dubai you
can begin the journey and you can talk
to the same people I've talked to and
then Hala did he get there did you teach
you've got a few noodle it's funny
shaytan is his favorite
he doesn't say Matrix he says yeah
so that's very uh nice to see he's
already uh and he he corrected the guy
he said that right away the person
connected with what he was saying he
said where's she at he said no no you
have to first become a Muslim yeah we
did a podcast and we spoke about we said
if a man or woman live by the values of
Islam and you respect the laws and live
by that you will never have a public
marriage either my wife that many people
won't will say we do we don't but if you
truly live by the principles of the
Quran and Sunnah and live by that and
you both respect each other I think
you'll never have a problem in life
honestly your only problems will be
calamities with family or this but
how many of us can say we do and it's a
beautiful thing the respect of our wife
the respect of the husband the duties
the the roles none of us really go by
but if we truly do we know we cannot
raise our voice our wife she's not the
same we cannot and then it becomes more
a peaceful house the kids are happier so
in a way it's right if you live what
Jimenez if you live by that kind of
a guidebook for me in life you have no
problems I really truly believe you're
more content whether you make money or
not your content business is different
it's
does
am I obeying Allah enough
am I getting myself inshallah to heaven
am I raising my kids the right way and
this is your
um goal in life rather than before it
will be different things and
of course we want to make money and
survive because we want to give shelter
to our family make sure they're okay and
education's good but
truly it changed me in a way where I
don't change materialistic things I
don't care for it I'm literally like you
know in a gym t-shirt shorts uh or after
the way I pray in my life honestly it
stems around being around my family kids
raising them
taking my girls sometimes to drama
they're only three but just to let them
feel it and don't push it just to let
them feel look this is our this is our
beautiful way of life I don't feel like
using the word religion and so while
it's a great thing and
for someone from me born and raised in
the UK living in Dubai which they call
the flashiest place and I've been around
you name it the Mayweather's that
so-called celebs I've been in this kind
of Lifestyle I've seen the private jets
also Yachts I
USC Fighters I train with them I used to
Freshly fight TV I've even acted in a
movie imagine with Jackie Chan but it
means nothing is
is so minute and
it's nothing the main there's no feel
like I was in when I can't explain when
I went to umarai Mecca the feeling of
praying and bowing and put my head to
the floor and into complete silence with
like thousands of other people that
feeling honestly it was like walking to
Arena of a fight times ten my heart was
pounding and when I first saw the Kaaba
for the first time that feeling I'll
never forget subhanah is I cannot
explain it it's superb
And if every Muslim should really uh
every Muslim who's prayed their whole
life looking at these carbas on the
prayer mats or on the Internet when you
first go wow like that changed my life
forever and inshallah I hope I'm blessed
to go many more times and do Hajj as
well
there's that picture of you guys and you
you mentioned you guys were with uh
Steven Seagal yeah how was he taken to
uh Islam at all or have you guys had a
discussion about it yeah we still have
to go similarly I know there's a stigma
about him in those West and he had a lot
of uh
controversy surrounding but he's
honestly a nice guy very straightforward
very old school kind of alpha male and
he respects it he says he lives in
Russia and Russia if you're going to get
a country which is close to a Muslim
State and I don't offend anyone I'm not
saying about their political alliances
I'm saying Russian Orthodox Christians
are very similar in a way uh the
households the respect they have for
those ones um the they don't like
entertaining certain kind of agendas
being pushed in their country is very
very similar I've been to Moscow many
times so he's based in he likes that
system and he when we speak he agrees
with everything he he understands he
understands why he's Muslim and he says
I understand I've been to the West I've
been to America they've killed religion
they're trying to put religion in a draw
right and those who just have molded to
it and they want basically the dollar or
democracy I don't know what they're
trying to push the agenda but that
religion keep it at home keep it during
I don't know their Christmas or their
Sunday gospel but it's not for society
whereas he he thinks otherwise and uh
yeah he respects a lot and um honestly
I've
there's not many people I've been around
in my life when you speak to my right
they don't respect it uh
there's many who even inshallah I mean
Andrew's brother respects it a lot
inshallah one day hopefully he's a very
good guy as well himself Tristan a very
straightforward good guy
um they've been raised well you can see
and you never know because uh when you
have an older brother who you respect to
look up to as well and they go a certain
way I know usually the younger brothers
kind of follow him past so who knows but
um
I think uh
what he's done is very good
for our younger youth in a way I'm not
saying he's going to be a role model
because our role model should always be
the prophet peace be over hunting but
these young guys who I feel feel ashamed
to be Muslim want to impress too much or
it's prayer time I can't pray in front
of them this girl might think I'm this
or this guy
he's put in a shame to that so that's
that's what I like and what do you see
in my podcast whether it's the rapper
six nine or whoever he always speaks
about Islam and yesterday a YouTuber in
UK made some derogatory comments
regarding Andrew which went viral and he
replied straight away regarding
defending the religion and defending uh
Allah so and now after me converting to
Islam he made a piece on one of his
podcasts saying that I'm not true in my
conversion and then insulted all Muslims
then the Muslims blow themselves up and
I should go blow myself up we should all
blow ourselves up making racist comments
about about an entire religion as if
that's somehow funny
let me tell you something my friend and
if true Jordan if you're watching this
this is a message directly to you
there are certain times in life you need
to know when to shut
there are certain things which are not
funny certain things are not Beyond
reprisal you don't sit and insult a
man's religion just like you don't
insult a man's entire company and the
people who work for him that's one thing
but to insult my religion
and the religion of billions of people
across the planet making ignorant jokes
about [ __ ] ourselves up thinking
that's going to go without consequence
You're Gonna Learn very quickly my
friend that that was a mistake these
things I like he's straight on it he
doesn't like it so he takes it to her
which is a sign you know beautiful so
there's uh one key thing I want to take
away from this I love how you and that's
trying to set a good example as far as
never leaving the Salat we know as as
Muslims that's the most important thing
right after the shahada that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens and earth and
Muhammad is a messenger and then you
start making the Salah praying just like
Jesus prayed and all the other prophets
that's the way they humbled themselves
and they pray to the creator of the
heavens and the Earth and you are
holding on firmly to that so inshallah
the Young shabab The Young Ones out
there and people who are scared right
they have this inferiority complex they
can see someone like you who's in the
position around a lot of different
famous people and uh wherever you're at
you're in a meeting it's time to make
Salat you're out of that meeting and
you're going to make Salah so inshallah
let's considered another great example
and uh and what you just said about
making this uh this umra this Hajj that
you were at the power of that so this
motivates some people also to to jump on
this cool I mean my next uh thing uh I
want to take Andrew to do umra that's
the next goal right now
see things uh it's no excuse but it's
very difficult the brother can't drive
somewhere if they spot his car we're
flocked came to the gym he can't leave
malls and I've never experienced this
I'm not like this but I've had Habib and
many guys come around but I've never
seen this
in a way it's scary so his life has
totally changed and before he reverted
so he cannot really experience some
things in public so for example if you
go to John Morrow's I'm actually you
have to really run out and it looks rude
people think it's arrogant it's not get
in the car because
when a hundred few hundred people want a
picture it becomes commotion a lot of
people go oh he's not rude it's just I'm
the one that's trying to force him so
when it calms down a little bit I'd love
to take him umrah because uh
obviously people recognize it could get
a little ridiculous but inshallah that's
the goal and also like you said about
Salah the only difference between us and
non-muslim is Salah you know so I mean
without that you are nothing and it
keeps you in check when you pray
the more you pray you've got what you
you tend to not want to do something
harm you say oh I've got my group oh
that feel guilty and so the youngsters
there's nothing to be ashamed we should
be proud of what we are the beautiful
religion and if you want a role model
read the stories of the Prophet peace
people read the source of the sahaba
um
the other profits they they'll make
their hairs on your neck God I mean
Warriors
stories of him uh Hazard Ali I mean when
they truly know this you will not want
another role model and uh calamities
whatever when you read the stories eyes
have stress and my brother said read
about Prophet Ayub and then you'll see
what uh pressures you have and I said oh
my God I'm I'm stressed about this and
Prophet are you what he went through or
each Prophet that's calamities they
winner who are we they were getting
tortured for spreading a message so we
could be where we are and we're in a
world where we're not going to be
tortured if you were to pray on a middle
of Times Square no one's going to say
anything to you and you're on the USA I
could go in the middle of Hyde Park
London no one says a thing we have no
excuse most business in the west they'll
say okay you can have time out to pray
exactly yes so there's no excuse we can
all say we're we're in some communist
state of the early 80s in Russia there's
no excuse so as Muslims if you truly are
Muslim and I don't want to sound like a
hypocrite but
if you're not praying why why do you
claim like at least to the basics that
we're not saying to be a dawi or do the
basics pray if you respect our mothers
we respect our grandmothers our fathers
why they gave us birth what about the
Creator
who created them gave us Heavens the
Earth These Eyes these noses lips our
bodies uh everything we can't even give
five minutes out of our day so that's
what used to make me think you know I'd
wake up for UFC but I could live my
quilt cover for fudger so now you know
subhana I've become a body clock I don't
even alarm really I I know when and it
just naturally I wake up so
alhamdulillah I hope it inshallah I'm
always on the path and
to the end of my days and I hope my kids
follow suit and inshallah I think we all
I hope we all
uh stand that path because for me it's
just it's the truth and we don't
understand the blessing we're two
disguised myself I can't talk also by
the seductions of the West and these
tools and movies or whatever but we'd
understand we're here for a test and a
test is saying shall I'll get into
Janine
what we'll have to will flatten what we
think is good here and when you truly
understand Islam and read you'll see
that there's nothing else that matters
that's so beautiful all this uh you know
putting things in perspective I want to
thank you and it reminds me of the
Hadith uh with the prophet Muhammad he
said just guiding one person to the Deen
is better than everything in this Dunya
so may God Almighty Allah rewards you
for helping to facilitate this and and
continue to share the message like
you've been doing it's amazing and this
is great advice for for the people out
there listening and look forward to
inshallah meeting with you one day soon
any time come at the moment with
pleasure will hold a seminar anytime you
want your family please it's our
pleasure and inshallah I'd love to come
there and uh hopefully things have come
down we'll bring brother Andrew to we'll
have a good catch up that's beautiful
look forward to it thank you my brothers
we've been told that uh they're out to
kill us all assalamualaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
Americans about Islam here's what they
said do you know anything about Islam No
do you know anything about Islam No
sadly do you know anything about Islam
uh not really do you know anything about
Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that they're
out to kill us all that's what you've
been told that Muslims are out to kill
you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum